[United States Navy Training Film. Nonclassified.
Copyright 1945 by Hugh Harman Productions,
Inc.]
[Commandments For Health]
[Drinking Water]
Lets consider water.
Not carbonated water or toilet water, but
just plain everyday water. H2O.
You probably never gave it a second thought.
It used to be when if you wanted a drink of
water, you just took it. But now ...
[Third Commandment Drinking Water] "Thou shalt
not drink water from any other source than
that designated, else thou become victim to
an unhappy fate more painful than Japanese
lead."
"Thou shalt use thy water sparingly and wisely
else thy days and thy brothers days shall
be numbered."
So Brother, in a combat area get your water
from a Lister bag.
It may not taste like the water from that
old oaken bucket, but it is pure and healthful.
Use it wisely!
When you're on a march under a blistering
hot sun, even that chlorine tastes good.
So good, that some jerks want to down it all
at once!
Like, eh, like our old friend, McGillicuddy.
Kinda hot ain't it, Mac?
[A tired looking solider nods slowly]
Well, why don't you take a drink?
[Gradually starts drinking larger portions
of water]
Here we go.
[Pours water over his head and into his pants
and soaks his feet in his water-filled hat]
Hmm. See what I mean? What a jerk.
For two months we've been begging him to take
a bath and now he does it.
[Marches proudly upright]
The Great McGillicuddy. Full of him and full
of water. An empty canteen and an empty head.
[A blistering hot sun blazes above as he marches]
Now let's see how far he gets.
[Begins to drag himself slowly]
Oh, beginning to drag it, eh?
[Is laying on a desert floor]
Now it's really getting hot! Hotter than it
was before, huh, Mac?
Oh, your tongue's dry isn't it, Mac? You know
what you ought to have?
You ought to have a nice, cool drink of water.
Why don't you look in your canteen? You started
out with plenty of water.
[Tries to suck water out of his empty canteen
but only a drop comes out]
There it is, Mac! Water! Get it, Mac!
[Manages to catch the drop on his tongue but
it evaporates]
Aw, that's a dirty low-down shame
Water...water...
All right, Mac. Don't get dramatic. After
all, you're only a couple of miles away from
camp.
[Spots an oasis nearby and runs towards it]
Water...water!
Mac. Mac, come back! Mac! Don't, Mac! Come
back! Come back here! STOP!
Listen, knucklehead. You can't drink that
water! It hasn't been inspected - it might
even be poison!
Yetta, yetta, yetta! Quit beating your gums.
[Dives into water and drinks it]
[Across the water a gorilla drinks the same
water, and afterwards collapses]
Now how do you feel about drinking that water?
Not so good, huh?
Let's take a look upstream and see what gives
that stuff its kick.
[Aerial view shows objects in the water upstream]
See, Mac? Here's you, here's the gorilla,
a few dead Japs, some pigs, and a native village.
What's wrong with the native village?
[Scrolls across an image of the village and
shows a head]
Very pretty, very pretty, but do you know
what that is?
That, McGillicuddy, is a head hunter's head.
[Toilet flushing]
Direct from the manufacturer to the consumer!
A prize in every package!
[Stomach is full of weird germs swimming around]
And brother, you've hit the jackpot.
[Releases gas and is rushed past a sign that
says 'To The Head']
[Immediately returns to the head while releasing
gas multiple times]
Monotonous isn't it, McGillicuddy?
[The End. MN 2808 c. 1945]